you can either build Talent or you can
buy it and so it's much faster to buy
Talent this is a quote from my wife
everyone thinks they're a good judge of
character until they get judged by the
people they hire but it's true if I want
to hire a video editor for example to
cut content then I want to look at their
track record show me the stuff that
you've already done the second piece is
here's some raws this is what I want go
make stuff and then I can have 10 guys
compete and the thing is is that there's
so much psychological bias of like I
like this guy he looks the way I look
blah blah blah that we don't let the
work do the talking Talent comes in all
forms and so all I really care about is
the productivity the output of the
person because it's usually one founder
that's breathing life into this thing
with lots of little helpers it's a
genius with a thousand hands if you
remove the genius there's nothing in
terms of like how we scale businesses in
acquisition.com we consider recruiting
to be our core and number one competency